ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding really
respected I'm not wearing my yes you are
we ready right now I'm not so what boy
why you lying online today okay and I'm
REE Drummond Pioneer Woman this is this
is Triple D on the ranch oh that would
be the best combo ever what Triple D Oh
what they are garage yeah I Yeti and REE
Drummond Guy Fieri Drummond would that
be the crab of a century
welcome back to the general Julian
podcast sometimes we do guy fury fan
fiction love that house good we are
gonna play a game today it's all lies Oh
live it's time oh that was Bruce Buffer
yeah dad dad we're in a real [ __ ] mood
right we're gonna [ __ ] move it listen
it's fine it's raining no I can't hear
the rain oh yeah it's really peaceful I
thought that was one of the dogs like
eating something yeah
y'all a nasty no it's been raining all
day and it's so so nice yeah you like it
I love the rain but I mean I think
everyone appreciates the rain in LA
because it frickin never happened it's
nasty here things need to get washed off
mmm yeah everything's nasty here no we
brought the dogs out we went to like
Studio City and Peach made a bunch of
friends while we were walking around was
really cute yeah she's really cute they
were good for it being raining yeah
they're pretty good I also just side
note I want to talk about because I want
to do it sometime we got one of those
Google home things like you to everyone
so I'll just like sends us stuff and
they sent us a Google home and I did
some snapshots with it so I don't think
we can do like a podcast or video
because people are getting annoyed that
it sets off like their Google phone or
something when you say okay yeah blank
good hell okay Google what time is it oh
you can hear it you know we started just
asking real trolli things and other
languages and she [ __ ] answers
answers like she she's Google so she's
basically Google Translate in that thing
as I say whatever okay how do you say
[ __ ] this [ __ ] boy she thought she said
no and then in Russian - she was doing
that and then also if you ask her what a
curse word means she'll define what it
means but it'll bleep out her saying my
actual curse word which is funny so we
got this game it is called super fight a
dink member family
dink family member gave it to me in
Seattle we've played this we play this
in um you play this in Palm Springs at
one time oh yeah uh let me it's pretty
fun
it's my fun gotta get notes here no no
no no I'm a drama thank you for videos
um let me see about your car
thank you for your video about your car
crafts they made me feel a lot less
anxious because of mine this gives you
an Jetta something fun something fun to
play what does that say a giggle I don't
know
chuckle chuckle Oh tink tink from Sarah
at booby pop thank you Sarah for movie
pop for the for the place we call Marble
poopy Bella beep boop bop no B Cooper oh
my god okay also another side note I'm
like super distracted right now we
started dying laughing in the car the
other day if we got two big dogs we made
them beep and Boop but then if you
separate them and you so if you're like
you show up at the vet you're like all
right what's your dog's name really god
this is good like he doesn't make sense
out of context of with beep beep would
be fine by side but Boop alone is so
weird like a giant poodle and a mantis
boo Boop
no I think he thought it was like a like
a German Shepherd yeah and he's like
like a military trainer is the thing
every dog responds to commands in German
and he's very serious and his name is
boom yeah um I would want to get a dog
like that like a trained dog you know
you pay like a lot of money
yeah they know I remember watching
something about Johnny Hendrix buying
one of those dogs yeah they're expensive
and you know you get them when they're
like but three or five already fully
trained
not like pet pets you know they're sort
of like they're at work they're kind of
always on the service time if they're
there for protection yeah they're there
are the service dogs yeah
anyway Boop long story short Boop so
basically superfight if you guys haven't
played it it's it's a game where I'll
just read it off the back superfight is
a game where you argue with your friends
about ridiculous fights the game is very
simple it's fun for all levels okay the
main deck consists of 500 cards you
split between character cards which are
the white cards and power and weaknesses
cards yes which are the black cards so
you use those cards to create a fight so
here's an example kindergarten class
that breathes fire and where it's
jetpack versus a pirate that swings a
shark on a change entirely why yours
would be somebody else it you just argue
your point or why your superhero weight
gets good yeah so let's just never
played with two people though it's gonna
happen well we've only played this once
you can play with two people yeah you
play we'd be screwed it's gonna be late
guys let's go let's get ready for my
argue mommy and daddy are fighting mommy
and daddy are fighting alright
I wish REE Drummond was in this game
like it's like we German oh no REE
Drummond is though she has a show called
the Pioneer Woman no no no I need some
help I don't know why though it like
cracks me the [ __ ] up like I like her
she she just I think she is an absolute
weirdo she cracks I think she is
incredibly weird and like it shines
through in moments where she's like
she'll say something like remember that
we were talking about the episode where
she just has this like meltdown her
husband on camera she loved me and then
he's like yeah babe were recording and
she's like what do you love about me and
works like no my favorite episode she
built her son tad or Todd or whatever
the [ __ ] person 8th birthday party she
built him a six-foot ice cream like
trough it was nasty and then she was
like oh you know the boys are out cut
and fade saw on the on the farmland or
whatever and I know they're gonna be
hungry so she fries up [ __ ] homemade
doughnuts and brings them out
like what a nasty snack on cotton
popping a nasty smell my god I'm REE
Drummond I'm REE Drummond I'm REE
Drummond anyway I'm the drummer all
right how do I do this I think you just
go so maybe you prepare them you know so
to the black ones are your powers and
this is what you are you get both powers
are you at the pick one these are powers
and weaknesses you get to you just draw
two of black mine is a written thing on
it oh oh yeah can you read our hey I am
Gandhi who is narcoleptic and has
telekinesis
wait so you get both powers yeah okay
and then we keep it and then whoever
dies like you have to like if I win
you'd have to keep trying to beat me
right yeah yeah the winner the winner
stays what are you oh we could do two at
a time all right
I'm I'm a demon that has a voodoo doll
of opponent and has tiny t-rex arms okay
what's yours again Gandhi who's
narcoleptic
it has telekinesis okay so you fall
asleep all the time and you can move
things like that renders your
telekinesis just not even existent or
every time to go to sleep I enter a new
level of telekinesis no no I says no you
know anyone sleeping or wait good try
but I've avoided all of you so you
barely even get any exams you can't even
reach the video I can't touch it
okay can you imagine a demon a tiny
little voodoo doll but can't put pins in
it cuz his arms are too short I think
that my guy beads here I think it's very
very very bold for someone to say
telekinesis lipstick you're gonna fall
asleep while you're moving stuff you
don't understand it's you can't even
speak to that if I tell if I have
telekinesis and I'm not collected that
is for a reason I know that my powers
telekinesis powers are amplified and
honed when I fall asleep so that is one
of my body falls asleep at random
that's not how narcolepsy works that's
how Gandhi's narcolepsy works because no
yes
you're talking about normal narcolepsy
I'm talking about the kind of narcolepsy
that's paired with telekinesis and and I
can make okay well can I make the
argument that Gandhi is dead we could
and he's our galactic or he's just
taking a nap
no he's dead he daddy's dead right I
don't like a thousand for centuries that
are you a thousand cuz then why you
laughing
I'm almost no no no no no we're nine
hundred ninety nine percent sure the
Gandhi is dead is Gandhi dead I feel so
stupid for he is not dead he's dead he
is not dumb he was wrong with you he's
alive he's 78 and he's 78 years young
with telekinesis he is not dead no and
you lose the round first you mean he's
dead no you're right I thought he was
dead he not dead just like some weird
Mandal Mandela know Gandhi Gandhi I knew
he wasn't dead when you said that I was
like wait you're wrong I mean I thought
that I didn't say wait so why'd you get
rid of your guy you're supposed to keep
I'm supposed to stay that's right so
give me Gandhi again get the [ __ ] out
your peach all right here's who's gonna
pick a new girl all right so one white
one and then two black ones
all right a saber-toothed tiger that
controls magnetism and duplicate one
opponent attribute okay so I control
magnetism and I'm telekinetic
recollected no oh no goodbye Gandhi you
dead goodbye you know what good is
what's gonna happen now this is what's
gonna you have fun you have to only
respond this is what's gonna happen in
this fight the saber-tooth tiger is
gonna with his mind control magnetism
and anything else he chooses and then
he's gonna walk up to Gandhi and
Gandhi's gonna be like I'm gonna take a
nap then he's gonna go a narcoleptic and
then he dies you win
yeah I know it when you win
you win the first card is crazy I can
duplicate one of your okay I'll still
find a way to beat that okay god yeah I
will catch you let me tell me tell me
rhinoceros who's constantly taking
selfies and is really hangry
wait really my gosh like you were making
that up no okay so first of all you have
no powers okay okay you don't like a
tight Instagram but you're just like oh
I think I'm just like no no think about
okay what magnetism can you [ __ ] with
I'll [ __ ] stop your stupid little
saber-tooth Tiger you did I will just
use my brain to move that car over there
and have it smash into you with your oh
that whole car out of the parking lot in
the [ __ ] rain forest yeah who says
we're fighting in a rain forest we're
fighting in her natural habitat which is
nowhere near anything oh yeah what what
is the saber-tooth - my phone I'm taking
so is a natural habitat dog they're
extinct
you're already dead I win I get to live
everywhere no no no sing - alright not
you it's true right angry okay can I
just say that can I just say something
if the if a rhinoceros takes this many
selfies he is so confident in himself he
can stop anyone in his way with all
these selfies he knows how good he looks
he's gonna walk up to the saber-tooth
Tiger the saber-toothed tiger fine
I don't duplicate your attributes I'm
also really good at selfies great you
great that's great you're just gonna
stab yourself the face of your phone cuz
you're controlling animal magnet or
magnetism with your mind I'm hangry
final magnetism and I can scramble your
debit cards and you thought a rhinoceros
regular wants to kill you but I ran an
asterisk is hangry wants to kill you way
faster Julian it's a valiant effort but
you know you though not Surratt's that
takes selfies and is hangry try again
all right you win
Cooper France are we keeping track of
yeah I'm winning you have a are we
keeping you one rack you won with Gandhi
and I won one it was one-on-one yeah
alright whatever we'll just keep
tracking our minds all right
yes yes check what is that I am a bull
who can take the form of anything I
touch and can blow winds up to 200 miles
an hour
Oh No
teach you here comes the wind blowing
bulb it can take the form of anything
that they touch wait but isn't that also
a bad thing can not does it wouldn't it
wouldn't say can if it meant
automatically assumes the form I have
the option so for instance of Kerman
naseous keeps licking you I could just
touch his tongue and then I am his
tongue all right so I'm a bull yeah but
I'm hold on I just I gotta say this okay
I'm a bull bulls can run pretty fast and
they can look pretty hard but on top of
that 200 miles per hour when have you
ever experienced anything close to that
because no you haven't
okay Julian but I still get to duplicate
one of your attributes take one so I
choose to take the form of anything that
they touch I touch you and now I can
blow when we're in a stalemate great job
yeah but I can still control magnet no
you're busy trying to control magnetism
so I [ __ ] you up with my wind you're
like hmm let's get a car from New York
and bring it out into the Sahara to beat
up this bull is two bulls go to the same
no and then meanwhile I'm just like when
you're like oh if I control magnetism
what if I just stick to something that's
metal and you can't blow me away again
in the animal kingdom what's metal tell
me something one thing that's metal out
in the wilderness one literally one the
core of the earth shut the [ __ ] up
how you lose I'm below boys fine
all right you can win but I know that
you didn't I I did win and don't say
okay look at you if I'd be you don't say
you can win like you've allowed me that
okay um I am my ex my powers aren't
clothes that are way too tight and long
metal claws that pop out of hands I
can't be anyone like this the top card
you lose every time just based on the
white card sorry all right
I am Canada I'm made of stone and can
hold breath forever
okay how does the country need to hold
his breath I'm made of stone okay I'm
gonna come up to Canada with my wind
blowin ass and how does a country holds
its breath I'm lost it doesn't matter
whether data basically just a country
okay did you can't beat me I'm a country
name one thing that can beat Canada in
the entire world
what can beat Canada if Canada was gonna
fight an earthquake okay I touch her
earthquake
I assume the role of an earthquake and
tsunami I am assuming I'm you don't get
to turn into whatever you want can thank
you song with anything my touch you said
an earthquake can destroy Canada I touch
an earthquake and then I am an
earthquake and you know earthquakes not
form that's me driving the mic come on
yeah I mean you win because I'm a
[ __ ] country
you're Canada all right fine you win
Good Friday all right here we go ready
I'm a blob I can't stop clapping and my
tongue can stretch and move it will okay
tell me what you would do to try to
fight me I would clap in here I would
annoy you to death basically
I never blow you away 200 miles an hour
yeah but I would stretch my tongue out
and wrap it around you and then stick to
you okay I would touch a volcano and
then you would wrap your tongue around
hot lava and then you die
fine all right you're gonna have to get
something better than blob to be me I am
a bowl who blows wind I'm your mom I'm
nine feet tall and I'm locked in an
antique divers helmet
oh I'm thought there's really no ru ru
alive because that doesn't seem like a
real suitable place to live it's just my
head also an antique divers helmet is
what a foot big how are you gonna fit
inside of that you're nine feet tall or
if you're any feet it's the size of my
head
like just cuz I'm tall doesn't mean I've
all really weird shaped head that
doesn't fit my divers helmet got it's
locked in there already
okay so I can't beat you at anything I
would jump in the water I would blow
wind underwater actually I'm not
underwater I just have a helmet on okay
um I would walk up to you but I would
yell at you and tell you to go your room
the mom thing is scary I think you might
have me on this one no I don't don't
even play no wait hold on is it your
mama's of the Bulls mom just says you
mr. Bo's mom I'm a vegan who is
figuratively on fire can possess
opponent for 30 seconds then gets very
tired like possessed like the devil yeah
okay
I mean that's pretty dumb I'm gonna
possess you I'm gonna possess you and
then I'm going money because you're
vegan I'm gonna touch a black hole and
then by the time I leave your body you
just warp yourself how do you not touch
a black hole you just put your hand out
and touch it
I don't know I think that's made up I
think you made that up fine I'm just
gonna blow in on the vegan I'm gonna
possess you and then I'm going to jump
off a cliff and then unpossessed you and
I'll just be really tired
you're dead you're dead no you're dead
you just like if you're dead no I'm not
in your I jump out of your body while
I'm halfway down the cliff you're dead
no you're dead
I'm falling yeah and as I'm about to hit
the ground you blow yourself up don't
[ __ ] me that's a great defense right
there what's your other power you can
take the form of anything that you touch
you know you dead
I'm not dead I can possess your body you
make whatever I want you to do do what
no you can possess my body for 30
seconds and so you can make me do
whatever you want yeah I possess your
body
I still like slit my [ __ ] throat oh
my god and then I leave your body oh my
god I don't want to play okay you win
Jesus finally Jesus slit the [ __ ]
Bulls throat man okay I'm Homer with
horrible self-esteem and has vertigrow
Wow you can't be anybody like Homer
Simpson maybe or Homer the writers
Odyssey hmm you can't be anyone
you have vertigo and horrible
self-esteem will we try again I really
have no argument nope
try again because I have a bad
self-esteem when I'm up high but I also
have bad self-esteem literally all the
time okay pick another card I'm REE
Drummond I'm REE Drummond I'm REE
Drummond hmm Genghis Khan in a
helicopter distracted by shiny things
you're [ __ ] you're all helicopters
shiny
hey stop scratching okay don't do that
you're [ __ ]
Doug I know I'm not you sure that you're
literally just a vegan
yeah but I'm figuratively on fire you're
that guy I can possess you for 30
seconds I make you do whatever I want
okay I'm gonna literally fly my
helicopter mm-hmm to where you are yeah
and right and right before I blow you
all to all hell I'm gonna like look at
my choppers and I'm like haha those
blades are shiny and then we're good you
did but you're also gonna kill yourself
by doing that what you get survive a
helicopter crash Sasha we have guns on
the helicopter it's a military
helicopter
let's say that it doesn't know it could
totally be like that little red one from
the YouTube spaces just like a door no
it's not on YouTube helicopter would say
it was in a helicopter if it's Genghis
Khan's helicopter Scottie pretty dope so
you have a boy I'm out fired get out no
I do I don't agree that you beat me
you're in a helicopter and you're
distracted by shiny things you can't
even focus
you would die in snow you get out get
into the car do you know it [ __ ] okay
I'm a pet rock who is made of mirrors
and believes that they are invisible oh
yeah yeah well seeing is believing and
since I look at myself in the mirror
that's I'm made of I see myself and I
believe it you have absolutely no
fighting power wanna be a pet rock
you're a vegan you don't harm anything
tell me what you would do to baby
oh you're a vegan you don't have
anything I win
you you do know I'm living things you're
a rock rock rock is how you hang that
rock has feelings look it doesn't I am a
pet rock I would know and I'm feeling
pretty accosted right now you know what
I'm not gonna lose soup it's made of
mirrors you can't even see this all
believe you're invisible I don't even
know who you're talking to I'm not here
right now that you can be invisible and
look at you it's the town crazy person
talking to himself again because no
one's here besides him Julian you Lou
I'm a living pet rock don't you dare try
to hurt me maybe you stand on living
things rights and I am a living thing
you are not who you incidentally cannot
see cuz I am invisible you think you're
invisible I can see you and you're made
of mirrors I can see myself in you oh so
you don't see me you see yourself that's
something you're gonna Janet huh look at
myself what what am I made up of what I
do today I was worth something and then
you're gonna go cry cuz your day was
crap and you lost her
Rock who wasn't even there turian know
you wake up in the morning feeling like
pet rock no glasses in the pepper get a
new set of cars really valiant effort no
that's my name valiant
alright I'm an octopus that can make a
force field while holding my breath and
shoots bees from my mouth how you shoot
bees underwater dog why don't you tell
me how a vegan is gonna beat this I'll
let you I'll let you struggle a little
bit before I alright fry destroy you I
don't want to hear your argument boy you
I mean you're right Oh at the bottom of
this card says I'm figuratively on fire
and literally oh well great you didn't
read that okay well I'm on fire so I
can't help it if you die by touching me
so you just die personal review shoot
bees at me they're gonna catch on fire
um honey honey I'm what's your other
thing I can make a force field dinner
alright yeah no I'm not gonna kill you
guys I'm a vegan I would probably just
slap you with one of my tentacles and
then kill you're tight alright I'm a
French Bulldog I'm armed with a portal
gun and I can read minds
okay do you know what the portal gun is
right it's like in the game portal yep
yeah you're [ __ ] because anything that
you're gonna do to me I can read your
mind and know beforehand
and I can defend myself octopus don't
have minds okay you can't read anything
if they can octave octopi are smart
octopuses have no minds octopi so my
eyes don't have brains
yes they do can't read it if it's not
there I don't know where you think
you're leading but I don't have a mind
that's so insulting to octopi a
biological fact
you saying doesn't have a physical brain
I'm saying it has it's literally just
skin no octopuses are inanimate object
no yes no okay great read my mind what
am I thinking about octopus thing no
you're like I'm gonna hold my breath and
put up my force field before you do that
I'm gonna shoot a portal gun at you see
then use that force field it's stupid
I got it at IKEA I don't use it I shoot
bees for my mouth and I don't have to
think about I just go bah
yeah but I shoot my mortal gun and then
they all just go through a portal and
where do they end up I don't know don't
know don't care
incorrect answer the correct answer is
they had they redirect back to me and I
woulda lost ya there's no that I just
beat me for you thanks Julian what a guy
I'm a good guy what a guy guy
Frankenstein can't turn left and is
wearing skis you [ __ ] you are so [ __ ]
okay your small self this is an actual
case of someone not having a brain you
cannot read Frankenstein's brain mine
brain my rent my rent right mind right
remember remember okay also if I if I
have no choice about being able to only
turn right you can't read what I'm doing
cuz I'm like I am going one way in life
she's just Frankenstein you can't turn
right yeah and you have skis on yeah
that's it yeah think about this scenario
I ride over on my ski something bumpy
screw comes loose um I see oh I got a
screw in my neck great put it back in
the ski I can go for Mom how are you
gonna kill me I could just get away from
miles I'll ski away from you you're a
French Bulldog you're gonna need food
and you don't know how to get it I have
a portal gun
you know the thumb how do you fire a
trigger on a gun I just shoot it and
they'll walk through it and go get some
food okay whoa
this is this is not a scholar and an a
genius this is a French Bulldog
yeah I'm not losing the fragrance guys
I'm not listening to French either
bulldog hold on is the dog like that in
Seattle of French yeah okay yeah that
dogs gonna [ __ ] me up yeah God who is
like [ __ ] just sitting there snorting
while he hugged every customer okay so
you're saying your main argument is that
you're just gonna be able to get away
from me quickly I'm on skis that is the
slowest looking dog I've ever seen if
we're not on snow it doesn't matter
it doesn't any of Emily we are on snow
we're on snuff now why does it adapt to
whatever environment you're we are doing
no no before you said nobody's done we
just talked about this when when we went
to the snow we're in the mountain on the
top we took the chair lift up together
no you shot the portal gun and ported us
to the top of the challenge imagine if
you tap or gun you have to take the
chairlift anymore
yeah be tight but we're not in the snow
ones no no Franklin just hit mad jump on
his skis yeah it gets to the bottom and
he falls upon sorry can you explain how
the French Bulldog can fire any sort of
gun I mean you're right but I'm not
losing a Frankenstein on skis also what
would a French Bulldog do with the
knowledge of someone else's mind it's
it's not gonna mail this alright alright
you know you okay
all right ease away with the W well
don't stop boy all right I'm Google's
no toxin and I have no arms okay here's
how I beat you I say ok Google
self-destruct oh what'd she say to that
I don't know
ok Google self-destruct
did you just count down yeah okay Google
full volume
okay Google off oh my god oh my god okay
stop okay Google stop oh my god it's
possessed I'm terrified right now we
asked our full volume
okay Google stop ok Google self-destruct
self-destructing it 3 2 1
actually I think I'll stick around Oh
she'd be playing games boy bet you would
what was it sorry for I don't know okay
yeah I mean you're right though you
really could just tell me the
self-destruct and I probably would well
are you Google or are you I'm Google so
having no arms is neither here nor there
it's not even your literally Google home
you're right just spray neurotoxin okay
Google stop spraying neurotoxins some
solving problems yeah that's ax saw them
problem solve them prob I am Iron Man
I can dig and run through tunnels with
SuperSpeed and there's ten of me you are
Fox boy
you are so [ __ ] no he's getting you
anything no you cannot see like skiing
away no I dig a tunnel underground as
fast as I can
pop up and punch you right in your
[ __ ] face and your friend inside neck
no boy mm-hmm take a new card daddy
you [ __ ] that's really adorable that
you think that you're skiing I'm Katniss
okay Everdeen is that what that means
huh with the three foot long fingernails
you know what I throw bears hi dammit no
I
no I'm not dead I'm not dead
I just touch you with my three-foot
fingertip I just you again now okay
I am Katniss running around my bow and
arrow like the tomboy that I am pick up
a bag throwing it all four of your iron
men and it domino effect ten of me
there's only four right here this
Donald's not a superhuman speed domino
effect the bear just crushes all of you
and wakes you as he's being thrown we're
in an underground tunnel your beer
doesn't want that [ __ ] you're in an
underground tunnel my big and run
through tunnels with super speed and
there's ten of me okay how are you gonna
throw a bear at me we're underground I
go up to the bear and I say hey Depot
[ __ ] home and then he digs a hole
kinda how hard it is smelly no bad dog
where do you get off where do you get
off Kremen so I dig I dig a hole no I
can't speak for fingernails
we're human speed all right I throw a
bear at Iron Man give a Julian if you're
throwing bears your fingernails will
break off no trust me three foot long
and extra strong it says let me see no
it says are you ready let me see let me
see
it just says three foot fingernails what
if it means three foot fingernails like
I only have three foot fingernails and I
just gotta rest of my feet have nothing
about it's disgusting I'm throwing bears
and bears and bears would get stuck on
your nail oh boy I'm throwing bears no
I'm thrown there no there's ten of me
antenna and then there's undercoat yeah
it's awesome I did I like throwing cards
I am Terminator armed with Catering's
what are Catering's I actually don't
know
what is a cat ring that's not what I
said
what is a cat Arang okay that's not what
I'm
why is your Siri like Australian she's
British because all series are British
you just have been listening mine isn't
it is no I did it to make myself seem
like I'm James Bond I throw burritos
also maternity what's your ear term name
I'm the Terminator burritos and arms of
cat so this comes down to an argument of
can the Terminator beat ten Iron Men
because I think he can no I think you
can I can dig tunnels great high the
right hideout well I'm just up on the
ground being dope there's ten of me yes
around enthrone usual term you love acid
I'm the Terminator pool of acid I'm the
Terminator doesn't hurt me Plus how do
you kill the Terminator
you gotta terminate him isn't he like a
robot though can I just pour water on
you that would have in a really short
movie if that was I guess I've never
really seen terminator I've seen in
years but no that's not how you kill him
not water well what then fruitcake news
calling a fruitcake no not a fruitcake
your way yeah like what's his weakness
it's like Arnold is walking through the
streets as terminator and then he's like
nothing can stop me and so I was like
you want some food Kings like oh yeah no
when he just like melts did you ever
have grandparents that made fruitcake my
mom used to make fruitcake well she used
to make um sponge cake mm-hm which was
like really fluffy like vanilla cake
with like strawberries oh no that's
totally different I didn't college food
cake I said it was sponge cake
I identified it what it was no fruit
cake is like it can be like bad
sometimes like real gross I kind of want
fruit cake the more you talk
amara wanna it's like nasty well do you
wanna go get some fruitcake no I don't
what is fruitcake made of is it made
morally a fruit more feet or more like a
deer dog all right Carmen we can making
growlers and stuff no I don't wanted to
growl come aground poor baby growl I
still think that you lose no Terminator
throws breo's dude no Julian
alright fine I lost all right redneck
with stone gays steals one attribute
from opponent discard this card after
use did you get the discard card often
no it isn't oh I didn't check I bet you
did okay I'm a redneck who can steal so
I'm gonna take the the ten of them
there's ten of you and you just have a
stony day stone guys you can't penetrate
that case that's not even like do
something
okay I'll stone gays you until you just
feel weird about yourself and you leave
into your tunnel no all 10 of me no I'm
putting my feet right here look at that
hey Julian you eat I'm still iron man
even if there's ten rednecks around me
I'm giving you the stone guys go ahead
try your best
no you can't do anything I'm Iron Man
iron versus stone stone no no nice try
the article table of elements
I strive no what no he's just staring
into the camera right now
I lost let's go
me hunchback who is agoraphobic and can
see three seconds into the future how
are you gonna beat me if you can't leave
your house I don't know I'm not I'm not
I'm always sorry I should have argued
that one oh no no no no okay
I am
I am men in black I am both men in black
I lay exploding eggs and I wear one of
those cones they put on pets to keep
them from licking themselves okay first
of all I'm gonna lay eggs so far into
your tunnels that you're all gonna blow
up it was a thanks can you exploding
eggs okay second of all I'm wearing a
dog cone and you're gonna think it's
just a dog so you're not gonna see me
you're gonna be like Oh like you know
Poochie pooch and then you're gonna go
look for me but that was me this was the
whole no you're men but the whole time
that was me I was one dog meat so your
wills explode exploding exploding eggs
just I rest my case
I'm Iron Man loading eggs is the perfect
defense for your shitty little tunnel
system I'm an Iron Man and I have
unlimited exploding a I just lay them on
my butt yeah company needs to like
fertilize them to be eggs right no
they're bombs I ain't dropping bombs on
my ass and I am no I know you're right
man but I just ride through your Iron
Man little tunnel drop all these bombs
yeah but a bomb doesn't affect Iron Man
the same way that it would a person it
still affects them and this isn't a bomb
this is an egg is twice as powerful as
an atomic bomb so you're dead you lay
one and you're dead at least you're dead
too you die first because it's closer to
your but it's a piece of cake bleh
explode Meigs I win scary you're Iron
Man I drop the eggs all of you talk I'll
let you win fine
you didn't let anything happen i won i
won
so I need to never do that I forget
people actually listen to this and don't
want it we'll just listen or watch I
sometimes I'm in here and we're
podcasting it and I don't ever think
it's ever gonna get seen all right
I am the player to your left does that
go all the way back round
yeah okay so I'm Julian and I can use
the Force and I'm in a spacesuit so I
just use the Force to just choke you off
into space choke me off which is choke
me off choke you off so it's choke you
out or jerk you off those or choke you I
just choke you off yeah okay yeah with
this art you win this but just say it
right don't say choke you off it's wrong
just choke y'all Froelich no no no choke
me off yeah just choking choking off
what that thing has a voice a voice push
a button on the side there's no bun
anywhere hmm push a button let me see it
no it's mine no it's not mine it is it
it's actually mine boy all right I win
choosing starts choke me off just see
off again choke me off at the ball game
you took me off at my house okay I am a
velociraptor it was a wall-crawler
riding a depressed Santa right there
that was not the left that's the right
all right go what is it Velociraptor
Velociraptor who's a wall-crawler who
rides a depressed centaur none of that
sounds like a power dog I win no you
lose now that win not cuz I'm just gonna
choke off you and your [ __ ] mmm
Velociraptor I'll just like eat your
whole face
you're also extinct
wall-crawler you think you can use the
force on me I'm will crawl a wall
alright bye riding a depressed Center
yeah so he can't even run I'm a wall
crawler i deserted you're extinct I'm a
wall crawler fine I use the force to
knock over your side torque finding me
I'm on a wall it's not that hard
what if we're in the middle of like a
field that there are no walls I switch
gravity and everything oh no oh actually
when you walk on the ground
damn let's get it up for that skill fine
John I switch gravity and everything
some wall I'm MacGyver mm-hmm armed with
a cattle prod and controls a tween army
do not lasso children tweens my army I'm
to the cattle prod yeah that's how I
control my shortening army I mean that's
a lot of people rod the tweens I'm like
go go get him if you have that sense I'm
not using the force on an army of tweens
I'll just be like yo [ __ ] get him
I'll get a follow back I don't think I
can [ __ ] with an army though
yeah but your your tween army really
doesn't give a [ __ ] about what you want
yeah it does really don't that does
they're my army they care about I can do
I control them do you see this I control
a tween army they are mine I say tween
don't I mean I don't have an army think
you win that I do win that this is a
good card army is deviant okay I am a
high school marching band that is also a
stuffed animal and can fly if nobody is
watching wow those are three really
useless things
so you're marching man but somehow
you're just one stuffed and one singular
stuffer you know ah [ __ ] now you're here
Kermit we let you in here that means you
can't cry while we podcast me new cards
alright help me talk rumors a stop is
crying turn bud stop it
dink dink dink okay I am conjoined twins
balancing on a circus ball and has a
time machine phone booth [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I will invade your phone kill you look
between our me and then when you appear
in a different time I would stab you
with my cattle prod you dead I'm so dead
no this is a power being a conjoined
twin is not helping just like well
sometimes aren't meant to be powers as
you meant to be handicaps Oh brutal how
am I gonna beaten or me okay I'm sure
let's have a best of three to end it
okay okay so this is number one I'm a
supermodel that controls an army of
flying monkeys [ __ ] yes and I'm armed
with a bacon-wrapped baseball bat okay
you are [ __ ] just hold on hold on my
flying monkey army will destroy your
tween army how do you know they're
flying monkeys oh my twins could be
flying I control them I could say fine
no no not at all
and I will hit them with my
bacon-wrapped baseball bat are you
[ __ ] yeah swine I can't believe it
you want I won Game one of the series
especially yeah I mean with a prehensile
tail prehensile tail what's that I'm
pretty sure that's like you know how
some people are born with a human tail
sort of it's like a tail it's like an
elongated spine that comes out of your
lower back okay and I'm locked in the
shark tank a shark cage oh you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] how are you gonna go
underwater with your water breathing
monkeys no I'm gonna take my bat that's
dipped in bacon and I'm gonna put it in
the water distract the shark and get my
monkeys to kill you your monkeys can't
go underwater
supermodel and I'm skinny your son I'm
gonna get right in that you skinny super
mama good lovin lifting up a bat let
alone that being anything you're gonna
drop that bat in the water sharks are
gonna eat that up and then come after
you and your stupid water and dying
monkeys they're flying monkeys not
swimming look he's a shark cage okay I
get all my monkeys to make a monkey
chain grab the cage from underwater and
fly upwards and then you're in the cage
and I can just tell you while you're in
the case are some of the monkeys part of
the chain underwater at one point yes he
can't be they can't breathe underwater I
can't I can't
well yeah they can't yeah they're bad
you see yeah they can no I'm saying they
hold their breath for how long just I'm
in a cage to get the cage didn't get out
you can't get a cage I am a great white
shark I was a good one Thai Thai that's
for the win all right I'm a polar bear
oh [ __ ]
who has a skunk on a stick and can only
move when the opponent moves okay I mean
you can swim that's the thing yeah and
now we can get you out of the cage and I
can kill the shark because I am a polar
bear I'm not a shark I'm a queen and
you're in a shark cage but there is no
shark in it no I'm I'm I'm just very
white Queen oh no no no you're a queen
in a shark cage is that right you're a
human I'm a polar bear but what if I
just don't move then you can't move okay
by the Sun I'm a happy in my shirt no no
listen all of eternity not fine budging
but listen muscle listen I have a skunk
on a stick
okay my skunk can move no and it's good
yes again it can spray the [ __ ] out of
you while you're in that cage so that
you have to move out of pure
uncomfortableness so yes no yes no
skunks can't spray underwater feels very
water I'm in a shark cage so I'm in a
shark cage but
doesn't say underwater it doesn't say
that there's a shark anywhere near it
but if it's a shark cage the only thing
about the cage that makes it a shark
cage is the fact that it houses a shark
in is underwater shark cages do not have
sharks there for people going underwater
to see sharks oh well this makes a lot
more sense
okay so I'm in just a cage then yes and
I'm just going to be breathing your
skull keep ooh yes and it like burns and
I have a tail though the prehensile tail
that might help hmm
it won't help anything you're dead I'm a
polar bear yeah all right I think you
got me on that one
I could literally just clog you with my
hand and pull your clean body through
the side and eat you limbani I can see
if I can see hey I am the win you are in
dead sammy-boy therapy boy well the site
for mommy and daddy fighting I feel like
this is gonna be a fun game when we have
a guest
oh yeah a three-person game but um thank
you I threw the note on the floor oh
right here um Sarah thank you Sarah for
this game oh you're sweet as fun as um
and thank you guys for hanging up I hope
you all have a really wonderful
Thanksgiving this week yeah our friends
giving or whatever you do and I hope you
have a nice holiday and eat a lot of
yummy food and Happy Thanksgiving less
you're Canadian because then you already
have it but also Happy Thanksgiving
yeah you're thinking you're Canadian
because you're Canada I am the Lord
Canada the whole place will be back next
week with another podcast and we love
you very much I will love you see you
guys on the next Dicky boy say goodbye
Kermit stink remember you breathe into
the right hand at please oh yeah ASMR
mckernon wait
why does he breathe like that I love you
guys see you later
hi I'm REE Drummond I'm the gun